I have to apologize I will take  responsibility for this easy can  exclusively report Steve Harvey will be  returning to the Miss Universe stage as  host despite the comedian's major mishap  during Sunday's pageants the first  runner-up is Columbia Miss Universe 2015  is Philippines a source close to the  production tells ET Harvey signed a  multi-year contract to host the show the  deal is for at least three years  possibly even as many as six or seven  and get this it's a big payday source  adds that Harvey will earn quote more  than they've ever paid before for a host  after the crowning catastrophe the  58-year old TV personality was  understandably quote mortified what the  Cox it was first runner-up I just didn't  really first run up announce the winners  which is a huge mistake I feel home for  the to win it was a mistake but the  blunder seemingly wasn't an issue with  production execs the source tells ET IMG  quote really loves him